okay we got a mission we've only just
begun okay I'm surprised the syndicate
is still standing after all the [ __ ]
we've thrown at them I don't theories
about not saying we should sure are you
at the focus lately you're gonzalo
lately I got a [ __ ] car here's on is
not thank you exit the vehicle like in
the guy stays on there
something just like turns I honor at
that oh oh
j says
that's a bad I can use a massage hey
love massages hey down hey down hello
hey guy sucks journal of test phase
Pierce what's the hate beer is cheap and
I'm the best looking [ __ ] in
here good luck you may think it's time
to kick back but I'm done toying with
these bastards i want l'wren and I want
him now so where is he no idea but 10k
says he's hiding out in that big a
skyscraper well it runs a tactician it's
not gonna hold up in a building that
screams I'm a criminal mastermind huh
yeah and it's something concrete to hit
up powder I don't have time for a
stripper no powders a designer gun store
downtown I saw some of the rinse thugs
talking to the owner there's got to be
something there let's go shopping okay
let's do it betcha that's it
[ __ ] that guy that sent I scar though
yeah that can I got then we had a
[ __ ] map
and the [ __ ] now that okay
want to go shopping want to go kill a
bunch of goons that work for l'wren
definitely believe owns a gun store in
town named powder want to go shagger see
you in five
give me a challenge [ __ ] cherries are
like invincible like every game Jesus
up
oh oh oh oh
[ __ ] Isley right here okay powder powder
let's do that's what got shooter one up
in here hello batter a lot of people
with guns in there will go in the back
way you don't think the backs guarded
there's like two punks what about beings
on their tits gotta put in your tampons
and let's do this she never has a tampon
she's let's play it I like that about
her okay that cat this group sucks this
one's all your best idea time you said
oh yeah I gotta call [ __ ] backup
inside will be safer
sniper aside a half [ __ ] whoever's in
charge here probably knows where to find
Lauren now let's get to the office and
find them
chef okay good yeah
what the [ __ ] is that minigun
you think your [ __ ] bird is with us
okay got got got got got got ya got ya
not now put it in this pie always win my
arguments
okay [ __ ] ow what [ __ ] sniped Wow
that's yeah [ __ ] getting my lad
get into that office it's not about what
they want so k
shut
feel good to kick ass okay goodnight
sake Prince looks like the manager went
home for the day I'll get what I can off
the computer
yes okay thanks hutch
dips out for her Amish